foreign
[Music]
yeah that's an accurate response welcome
to things you missed we sure wish we
missed this one Jimmy how did this all
come together the first title they came
up with was Halloween the homecoming but
the producers switched it because after
Halloween h2o's ending they were nervous
people would only show up if they knew
for a fact Michael Myers was Back to
Life the director of Halloween 2 was
brought back for this one but he was
actually the third choice after Whitney
Rancic who I personally unfortunately
have never heard of sorry if they're
like a huge director or something like
that
and Dwight H little the director of
Halloween 4 who I really would have
liked to see come back I think he
deserved a second shot at Halloween but
neither of them wanted to so they went
with Rick Rosenthal ah yes our old
friend Rick not Rick Moranis not Rico
Kasich hell not even a Rick Astley Rick
and Rosenthal the director of Halloween
2 from 1981. Rick was put in a pretty
tough spot to be fair retconning the end
of H2O by saying that Michael Myers
wasn't the one who got killed was never
going to be popular and killing off Lori
Strode in the first 10 minutes is maybe
even a bigger slap in the audience's
face but remember while old wreck might
be the one who delivered that slap his
hand was Guided by Malacca Cod so given
the hand he was dealt did he do an okay
job not even remotely let's get into the
things you missed before I puke
sponsored by ridgewallet the slim modern
wallet that holds up to 12 cards plus
cash in over 30 colors including carbon
fiber and burnt titanium it's durable
and comes with a lifetime warranty plus
every dollar you spend on Ridge wallet
before September 30th enters you to win
a brand new upgraded Ford Bronco check
out the link in the description and use
code sees these worlds for 10 off
[Music]
thank you
the film begins with Laurie schroed
right away in a sanitarium after going
crazy after killing a paramedic whom she
believed to be Michael Myers as much as
we're gonna crap on this movie and
believe us we are going to crap on this
movie you have to give it a tiny bit of
credit for introducing some ideas that
were used years later in Halloween 2018
and Halloween kills in a much better way
both Resurrection in 2018 used the idea
of Lori being the crazy one now and in
Resurrection they take it even farther
by putting her in the sanitarium instead
of Michael the established roles are
reversed she's even gone mute in this
one she hasn't said a word in years
extreme dissociative disorder no she
doesn't stare out that window
coincidentally staring out the window is
just what Michael does in the Myers
house and Halloween kills Lori is just
like Mike not to be confused with like
Mike which also came out in 2002 and
from what I remember was a much better
movie the intro also features Lori
setting a trap for Michael something
that's used later in Halloween 2018 and
this very specific scenario of someone
getting injured on the staircase in the
Meyer's house with Michael about to
strike before are getting distracted and
drawn away by another potential Victor
this exact circumstance is seen again
later in Halloween kills there's even a
line early on likening Michael Myers to
a great white shark
he's the great white shark of our
unconscious I'll talk about this more in
depth in a future Horror history but the
filmmakers actually use Jaws as a
template for Michael Myers in the
40-year trilogy and it ended up being
this very strange mannequin-like you
know soulless almost great white shark
of a human
love that guy oh and don't forget that
Lori is the one dropped from the rooftop
during the intro sequence just like she
was in Halloween 2018 which is a
reversal of what happens in the original
Halloween where Michael is the one who
falls and feels the Relentless pull of
gravity we first meet Lori and her cell
at the sanitarium and she's got this
Ragdoll similar to the doll scene in her
room way back in 1978 later on the same
doll as seen on the desk of our
protagonist Sarah Moyer perhaps this was
old Rick's way of telling us that Sarah
is the new protagonist now the
interesting thing I learned back in 2018
when I reviewed this movie is that the
lead actress Bianca kalich actually
can't scream so every time you hear her
scream in this movie it's dubbed and
that gets even weirder when you consider
that the whole reason she's in the Myers
house in the first place is because
she's supposedly the ultimate scream
Queen it's kind of weird but ultimately
it's like the least of this movie's
problems the perfect introduction to the
level of care put into this movie can be
observed in these two nurses Phillips
and Wells that's
w-e-l-l-e-s even though it's spelled
differently in the end credits to be
fair Halloween 1 and 2 also had errors
in the end credits stating that Michael
Myers was 23 years old rather than 21.
another patient at the sanitarium is
named Harold who is more True Crime
obsessed than my mom we first see him
hiding behind this tree as the security
guard patrols the grounds maybe the only
intentionally creepy moments that the
movie has to offer he's wearing a clown
costume which brings memories of the
original Halloween opening where Michael
Myers supported a clown seat of his own
but he's actually dressed as John Wayne
Gacy a fellow illinois-born serial
criminal who performed as a clown for
children's events he means fellow to
Michael Myers not fellow to himself
right Zach no comments like Michael most
of Gacy's victims were teenagers ranging
in age from 14 to 21. being old Rick's
first foray into the Halloween franchise
in 21 years Resurrection has a lot of
callbacks to Halloween too whether it be
the shot of the Night Guard locating
Michael on the security monitors the
opening taking place in the hospital or
even this scene where a character slips
and falls in a puddle of red arterial
fluid we saw the medic Jimmy do just
that back in the second movie literally
every time you say that I look over
you'd think I'd be used to that by now
yeah this is your eighth time being on
this channel which means this is going
to be the sixth time that we talk about
Halloween's white sheet Motif because
it's not in Halloween three or four
Michael appearing behind bed sheets sort
of became a meme after the first movie
and plenty of the sequels took no in
Halloween resurrection the security
guard Willie investigates the laundry
room where we see a basket of bed sheets
and then a minute later he discovers his
partner's blood in the laundry machine
which is similar to Halloween 6 where
John Strode the most hateable character
in the franchise goes into the basement
of his house and finds the aftermath of
his wife's encounter with Michael Myers
I did not mean for that to sound as
dirty as it did we first meet our main
character Sarah Moyer in the middle of
one of her college classes yeah
Haddonfield University is back after its
first appearance in Halloween the curse
of Michael Myers and the professor is a
cameo from none other than old Rick
himself his character's name is Doctor
Mixter Dr mixer's class I'm taking that
course too which was the name of the
head position at the hospital back in
Rick's Halloween too can we call it that
I mean people call the 2009 entry Rob
Zombie's Halloween 2 so I don't really
see a problem with it he's also giving a
lesson on the collective unconscious
which is the main theme explored in
Halloween 2. where Lori's relationship
to Michael is buried deep within her
unconscious mind if you want to know
more about that we actually talked a lot
about it in the Halloween two things you
missed our Rick's Halloween two things
you missed exactly after class Jen and
her friends scooter through campus where
you can see a poster for a Halloween
dance this is probably a different dance
than the one Lori and Annie made plans
for in the original Halloween because
that was for a high school dance and
these posters are on a college campus
but it still brings back memories of the
original and eventually Halloween 2018.
Halloween resurrection is all about this
reality show called danger attainment
which planned to send six college
students to investigate the Myers house
on Halloween night with the contestants
selected the fun or lack thereof would
have soon began and as always it would
contain a few things you missed
[Music]
the producer of Day entertainment is
this guy Freddy whose interests includes
saying profanity and watching old kung
fu movies the latter is a foreshadowing
for his character who would use martial
arts to attack Michael Myers
to get ready for the entertainment shoot
Sarah and Jen shop for clothes in a
boutique next to a grocery store which
proudly displays a Dracula 2000 poster
I've never seen a supermarket promoting
a horror movie before so it's obvious
that this is here because Resurrection
is made by Dimension films who also made
Dracula 2000. we saw a dimension trying
to promote their other properties in the
last two Halloween movies The Curse of
Michael Myers and H2O Dimension is also
owned by Miramax who released the 1994
Classic Pulp Fiction which could explain
why college students miles and Scott
dress up as characters from Pulp Fiction
for a costume party I can't think of any
other significant reason for this
reference can you no that makes sense
because Pulp Fiction is awesome and also
I just remembered Superbad follows the
same structure as Pulp Fiction and I
think that's what makes it the best
comedy of all time also when Sarah is
browsing costumes with her classmates
she briefly sees Michael Myers in a
reflection but turns immediately to find
some random kid this moment is never
explained the only thing I can figure is
that Sarah had expressed thoughts about
dropping out of the show due to being
too freaked out to sleep maybe she
started having hallucinations of Michael
Myers as well whatever the case may be
the scene is a Big callback to Halloween
for the return of Michael Myers where
Jamie Lloyd similarly sees the Boogeyman
in a mirror while browsing costumes and
freaks out
Michael's boutique store visit isn't the
only appearance of his that goes
completely unexplained in the movie when
danger attainment contestant Bill sneaks
up on gen to scare her the camera
glitches out for no apparent reason and
during which we see one frame of Michael
Myers none of them have encountered
Michael yet at this point so it's not
like supposed to be a Cloverfield like
effect where we're seeing previously
recorded footage you could say that this
was more of a malignant type of thing
where Michael found a way to
telepathically communicate through audio
and video devices but again that's not
something that ever happens in this
movie the same kind of thing happens
again at the end of the movie but this
time on the news cameras which makes
even less sense because they weren't
even there for anything that happened in
the house the sad thing is I actually
really like the idea of a found footage
Halloween movie the franchise is so
stale and I think approaching Michael
Myers through found footage could be a
great way to make him scary and
mysterious again but this ain't it Rick
this ain't it Friday the 13th almost
came back as a found footage movie after
the 2009 reboot but for a variety of
reasons that version of the movie never
got off the ground and still all these
years later I really would like to see
it as Freddie's assistant Nora gets
ready for the show she gets up to grab
coffee while dancing to a song she knows
the camera tilt down to her ass and then
back up so we can see what she's
actually doing is one of the most
blatantly forced eye candy moments I've
ever seen they easily could have just
used a different lens to get some booty
in frame but no our boy Rick was down
bad on this one Nora also calls a tow
truck to remove a car parked in front of
the house given the level of care put
into this movie I'm sure the fact that
the license plate says 6395 Bears no
real significance but as someone who is
always on the lookout for Easter eggs
and secrets my initial thought was that
these were the years that the initial
Halloween timeline took place it started
when Michael was a kid in 1963 and ended
when Michael confronted Loomis for the
final time in 1995. 63 and 95.
coincidence I think
besides none of the other license plates
in the film seem to reference anything
notable the characters split off into
three groups and of course we follow the
two characters who weren't even in the
movie before this point save for one
quick sound bite so why would we care
what happens to them there's definitely
some flirtation going on between them
but the girl Donna has a comeback that
cuts even deeper than Michael Myers
knife
besides
screwing a music Major would be
tantamount to lesbianism I'm pretty sure
John Carpenter the director of the
original Halloween was a music Major at
Western Kentucky University before
transferring to USC to study film so
that line is either a really funny jab
or a painfully awkward mistake I don't
know the exact relationship between
Rosenthal and Carpenter but based on
what carpenter has said about Halloween
2 over the years I would guess this line
is intentional speaking of Halloween 1
Sarah finds herself in a situation
that's very comparable to what happens
to Lori Strode she investigates a
shuttered closet and gets scared by a
dummy that falls on it her friend Rudy
instead of Simply opening the closet
just punches his hands straight through
it which is obviously reminiscent of
what Michael does when Lori is the one
Trapped in the Closet at the end of
Halloween one this is what we call a
dumb Easter egg not only does it not add
anything to the movie but everyone who
just saw it is dumber after witnessing
it down in the basement Donna is scared
by a rat which is something that happens
in the only other movie in this
franchise where the Myers house is shown
to have a basement Halloween 5 the
Revenge of Michael Myers basically if
you see a Myer's house with a basement
you can assume you're in for a bad time
Donna later discovers that Michael has
been surviving in the basement by eating
rats and that's a call back to the
original movie when bracket and Loomis
discover the half-eaten dog in the
Meyer's house it is also in this
basement where she stumbles upon this
article about Lori shroud I guess this
is supposed to tell us that Michael has
been keeping tabs on her all this time
which we already knew from H2O and we
don't really need to know because Lori's
already dead Donna reads out the
supposed headline
Glory strodes sister of Michael
which doesn't match what the text
actually says Laurie Strode has been
nominated by the Chamber of Commerce as
the most commonly something teen I can't
make out what that word is I spent like
10 minutes trying to figure it out and
was not willing to waste any more of my
life with a my new detail from the worst
Halloween movie Zach and I took a super
close look and we both think it says
spirited but the most commonly spirited
teen doesn't really make sense so I
don't really know or care it's just
weird and we wanted to point it out the
picture chosen for the article is
interesting though it's actually this
behind the scenes photo taken during the
production of the original Halloween and
during the scene where Lori waits for a
pickup from Annie right outside her
house if anyone wants to make their own
version of this photo you can still go
to the location and they even leave a
pumpkin out to use as a prop Donna
nearly hooks up with her fellow
contestant Jim yes another gym in the
Halloween Universe it's getting old at
this point which by the way is really
stupid because the whole reason they're
there is to be filmed and they know
they're on camera so why wouldn't you
just wait till after the show to hook up
after this Donna gets dressed and
explores the basement more which is when
she has her encounter with Michael Myers
he kills her by impaling her on this
crooked beam that's sticking out of the
gate during which she is somehow
magically wearing a bra again which is
weird because earlier we saw her put her
shirt back on and she's very clearly not
wearing a bra I just can't believe Rick
would let this slide once the Bloodshed
begins it doesn't stop but if we take a
closer look at some of these kills we
can find a few more anomalies
another Halloween franchise Trope that
happens in this movie is the one where
someone is mistaken for Michael Myers
and pays the price for it the first time
we saw this was with Ben tramer in
Rick's Halloween 2 the rip then Ted
Hollister in Halloween 4.
[Music]
foreign
Resurrection it's the producer Freddy we
can actually see the Michael Myers mask
on his desk before he goes into the
house with it and gets attacked by Jim
unlike Ben Ted and Spitz Freddy survive
Sarah's friend Jen is not so lucky she
gets decapitated by the real Michael
Myers not you after which we can see the
inside of the mannequin's neck they
didn't add any visual effects here to
make it look real I normally don't mind
cheesy effects in a low-budget horror
movie but the problem here is that one
of the plot points of this movie is
literally that the house is filled with
mannequins and Halloween decorations
staged by the entertainment production
team so it's unclear if we're supposed
to believe that Jen's death is staged or
real which is exactly how the internet
viewers at the Halloween party react
Smiles thinks it's real and calls the
police and gets connected immediately
because the makers of this movie have no
idea how a phone call works
yeah hello 9-1-1 this has been real
9-1-1 calls that actually happened Rudy
is the next character to confront
Michael I know his whole character is
him being a chef and all he thinks about
is nutrition but I love how that's still
the only thing he talks about as he's
facing certain death
you should try a little less protein
diet you know control somebody I don't
even know if that's a thing the only
reputable study I've been able to find
linking's protein and aggression was
studying dogs do you think dogs are a
good source of protein I don't want to
find out but according to this movie
rats are a perfectly fine source of
protein Rudy gets to be the victim of
the knife pen kale also known as the Bob
Sims kill the Kelly Meeker kill the
nurse Mary kill the day of kill whatever
you want to call it Sarah ends up being
the only remaining contestant so Miles
also known as Deckard sends her text
messages to alert her of Michael's
position in the house like this one
where he informs her that Michael is in
the hallway and says don't scream to
which she immediately screams
what a dumbass she's even worse than
Nina from Saw seven
Sarah climbs out through the window
under the roof twist
Rachel and Jamie in Halloween 4. I'm
gonna believe it is because I love
Halloween 4. I also find it really funny
that Michael opens the window by
headbutting it I guess people in this
movie just really like to break things
instead of opening them as we already
mentioned Sarah is just not the
brightest I don't know how she even got
accepted into Haddonfield University
because instead of going to the lowest
point of the roof and jumping she goes
back into the house to escape you know
the house for the serial killer is I
mean the roof isn't even that high it
certainly seems safer to jump rather
than climbing over the body hanging from
the attic stairs for a moment there it
looks like she's about to Spider-Man
kiss the corpse which is funny if you
consider that Spider-Man was still in
theaters when Resurrection came out in
July of 2002. Freddie comes back to the
house to save Sarah and drops this line
on Michael so you want to be on danger
tame it not only is that a terrible line
but Michael's reaction is certainly meme
worthy you're in his house imagine if I
broke into someone's house to ask them
if they wanted to be on things you
missed in true Rick Rosenthal Halloween
movie fashion it ends with Michael being
lit on fire things get a little bit
dicey for Sarah when she gets pinned
down by a mixing board are you [ __ ]
serious anyway Freddie saves her by
electrocuting Michael Myers in the penis
which sends him flying across the room
apparently it's good to know that
Michael's one weakness is being
electrocuted in the penis there are
actually Four endings to this movie one
where Michael comes back to life on the
journey and is immediately killed by an
ax that Sarah somehow has one where she
meets Deckard miles in real life and he
says well he did it
who killed The Boogeyman
which is the Callback to Tommy Doyle's
line in the original movie he can't kill
the boogeyman
and one where crime scene investigators
are let in by this cop who is played by
Brad Laurie the actor under the Michael
Myers nice throughout the movie and that
one ends with Michael reaching out of
the wreckage to grab the investigator as
a one last scare moment supposedly Rick
wanted to send a different versions of
the film out to different theaters so
that the ending you got could have been
any one of these four this tactic was
used for the 1985 film clue I actually
think it's a cool idea but the studio
rejected it it's probably realizing that
it was a tactic that would only build
hype if the movie was actually good so
the ending scene of the movie shows
Michael coming back to life in the
morgue which obviously finally gives
meaning to the title of Halloween
Resurrection I think that's why they
called it that anyway because there's no
other resurrection that happens in this
movie this movie also went through
several different titles before it came
out we already mentioned Halloween
homecoming but there was also Halloween
h2k which I guess is a riff on Y2K which
is kind of weird because it happened a
few years before this movie came out and
also Halloween Michael myers.com yes
Halloween Michael myers.com wow that is
one of the worst titles I've ever heard
ultimately I find it pretty funny that
they decided on how being Resurrection
now there's something so ironic about
Resurrection being the one to kill your
franchise Halloween resurrection was so
bad that they decided to end the 20-year
timeline and start fresh five years
later with Rob Zombie's remake of
Halloween however we're gonna skip ahead
and talk about the 40-year timeline next
so get ready if you want to hear
everything you might have missed in
Halloween 2018 Halloween kills and
Halloween ends look out for those new
episodes in the playlist on the left
thanks to Jimmy champagne for joining me
once again and remember to subscribe to
cz's world for new Horrors every week
ring the death bell and select all
notifications and I will see you in the
next one assuming we both survive oh we
made it we made it
America
[Music]